los líderes y la oposición de venezuela
están divididos sobre la mayoría de
temas y la vacunación del cobi 19 no es
una excepción la vicepresidenta de
venezuela del xiv rodríguez informó que
el gobierno pagó la mitad del precio
para la adquisición de más de 10
millones de dosis a través del mecanismo
kóvacs yakovac recibió el equivalente a
50 y 3.8 millones de euros a lo que la
oposición respondió que esto prueba que
el gobierno mintió cuando dijo que no
podía pagar estas dosis antes debido a
las sanciones dicen ahora recientemente
que no que es que está bloqueada un
recurso o comprar los 100 millones de
dosis
lista en bloqueo a los recursos según
datos oficiales más de 170 mil
venezolanos se han contagiado de kobe 19
más de 1.700 han muerto pero el número
de casos podría ser mucho mayor la gente
está haciendo fila para obtener oxígeno
para los enfermos
hay mucha gente pero sin recursos
dame medicinas
necesitamos ayuda necesitamos de toda
esta gente
los venezolanos han enfrentado escasez
de medicamentos y otros productos
básicos como alimentos durante años la
oposición aún culpa a nicolás maduro de
la crisis el presidente dice que los
problemas se deben a las sanciones de
eeuu una escasez que ha empeorado con la
pandemia